hello konnichiwa everybody today we're
playing scorn a horror game although you
amnesia jump-scare loving freaks might
be a little disappointed this one has a
different approach to horror being a
little bit more subtle I'm super excited
for this game it was launched as a
Kickstarter and I helped fund it yay for
me
supporting developers yes I am a saint
thank you very much the trailer for this
game is so good
I really hope the gameplay lives up to
the trailer
[Music]
this is so disturbing in every single
way it reminds me of two artists which I
can't pronounce the name of any one of
them love beats in ski and HR Giger of
course enough of all this [ __ ] let's
let's play the game
is it good put on some headphones turn
on the light and put it put it on
fullscreen baby cuz here we go of course
I used my comp ass thingy to go through
here wow this place looks lovely it's
apparently a serbian developer and the
game is supposed to be released on
october next year why don't we go
straight left right now all the option
looks equally horrible let's go right
you know what i bet no one's going right
is that a tentacle thank you also
drawing inspire inspiration from
japanese hand-tied this game how great
oh wow look at that oh it gets worse
it's in the head great yeah
yuck well what am i how do I look like
ah disgusting let's show the comp ass
whoa wait I have a gun oh hell yeah
I didn't realize there's no real user
interface sorry what did I just do yeah
I'm holding on cue
it was that a little dog what the [ __ ]
okay let's not hold down cue let's go
back you know what screw that Hut at
place stupid now I'm scared of pressing
buttons on my keyboard
okay well going right was clearly the
wrong option that's okay that's okay
that will go straightened from now on oh
this is a compact door hello mr. comp s
door there you go let me show you my
Amelie
Oh God this really actually does remind
me of Manisha just cuz fear of the
unknown I never played a horror game
like this so I don't know what the heck
is gonna I can't use it what if I show
you it looks like I need to stick my
hand in there maybe I'm missing
something that's giving me a big red
bars
it looks like I can't go there either
disgusting by the way
just a mix of like awful alien things
and human flesh it's just like so nasty
to me man I really fit others I need to
learn how to play this game we have the
exhauster all our options so please let
there be something great down here
something a nice cup of soup perhaps oh
look at that
oh there's no soup here a different kind
of soup great this looks fantastic
our what our order uh yeah yucky yuck
that's a great man once said it was me
Oh No
No is it coming here what how up it's
fast I can't see anything
well I just got rekt dude here I come
it's me
okay your son of a [ __ ] okay all right
I'm ready I have trained in the art of
combat tree you ugly son of the MA it's
not working I need a reload I got one
Marcia Prague
hey hey no hey al can we not let me just
disgusting does that not freak you out
putting those things in excuse me I'm a
late door I believe I have an envelope
you know what I don't want to go there
anyway yeah oh my
wait this is open now oh no it's another
one of the East oh yeah no no no it's
here now we can use that the hand thing
oh I'm moving it over there it's like an
on and off switch so detail Oh No
that's the door open now I think I did
something oh I need to press Miami let
there of course oh I see so I upgraded
oh my god
okay I see it now my space fidget
spinner has been improved
thank you everybody I will grab that now
Oh lovely it's blue now so now we can
open blue doors excellent just what I
wanted more spooky Dookie all right mr.
blue door thank you okay doing pretty
good easy oh it's a space elevator Oh
oh no [ __ ] I shouldn't have done that
press the button
please don't time I have to do redo
everything I got to redo everything huh
you know what there was plenty of blue
doors from before I don't need that blue
door thank you very much
I do recall there being a blue door
action XO alley blues are here much
better blue door look at that
thank you don't insta-kill me
all right who wants some Oh God
okay all right got him
[Music]
sorry space cow dog thing baby sorry
sumimasen okay
you have to die for the great greater
good of tentacle hentai all right oh wow
this just a sister subscribe I love the
place the wallpapers great don't kill me
I'm just gonna press this button oh look
at that giant began test score 11 door
pata pata pata is that where we were in
the beginning I think it is I think it
is that looks great and then we can walk
hey no no don't shoot me
listen listen I'm sorry
hello oh god there's more okay kick it
oh that's two more stay up wait space
baby and try to believe the headshot in
Boots that's right no there's more
there's more reload
ya know take your time putting in those
reverse pimples man alright alright
alright space dog we're good
good sheep shut up shut up my god stop
face pimple return quiet
quiet you I'm I'll be there I'll be that
those [ __ ] are gonna fall down you
don't think I don't think that you're
not gonna don't touch me okay
don't touch me space monkey baby baby
space what do you want look how many
there are
well they fly oh no this is like doom
dude I hate those flying [ __ ] go in
here now
God this is where we were before isn't
it yeah okay so that was like a shortcut
it's a bit disorienting but it's also
kind of cool how it connects so where
did we walk what did I say they just
don't effing listen
no no no did they see me one of them
must have go [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm out of ammo how much do I have three
bullets damn this is intense man all
right we're gonna have to make every
bullet count at this point
okay we're fine
George okay we're fine he went away
all right yes let's go
show him the Amalek push hey Oh what is
this oh dude I don't know I do not have
enough okay
is he dead he's not done yet I get him
oh no oh I'm not dead I'm dead no it's
cool cuz we know the shortcut everybody
be quiet
thank you so lame you guys are so lame
look he's doing hahahahaha oh wow is
this a blender everybody it's a space
blender how could I have been so scared
by their space blenders I don't know I
guess what happens when you play an
alpha - it's fun oh yeah this one [ __ ]
up space basket Christian demo
not today cuz booty pay has more pimples
thank you
I can't believe I died there oh my god
really I died at the end great well
there you go at least I can say that I
played it to its fullest okay that was
scorn what did you think I'm very
excited for the full version I think
finally finally a horror game doing
something a little bit different my god
did it have at Mysterio it was I was
genuinely freaked out playing it and I
think probably you are watching it as
well so thank you for tagging along
appreciate it and yeah look forward to
the full version that's it for me for
now remember to don't have space pimples
squad fam out